drew luck
took him a while to get onto the field
last year because of a wrist injury but
we saw enough at least i saw enough
to factor in everything the denver
broncos have going on to put them at
number 15 in our preseason power
rankings when i published these a few
weeks ago chris that placement of the
broncos
drew more complaints than any other
placement except from people in denver
and other broncos throughout the country
because there are still plenty of them
but i i can't deny
what i believe about this team i believe
in drew locke i believe in vic fangio as
the head coach and i think in year two
of this experiment if locke can stay
healthy and he doesn't have a pre-season
to get injured in this year unlike last
year if he can stay healthy
he he can uh
he can be great and the broncos can
finally snap this uncharacteristic slide
of three straight losing seasons he
excites you i mean so yeah and when you
have a quarterback you know of a team
that's got potential and then you think
ooh that quarterback i saw some special
talent yeah that leads us to think oh we
might see a special team or some special
things from that team this year so i'm
with you there mike all the way and then
you know listen would i have put them
maybe that high i'm not so sure i would
have but i understand that i'm not going
to sit here and go oh man florio's crazy
he's totally just lost his mind no
but because i understand like what
you're seeing it to me it does make
sense first off i mean free agency
killed it this year jarrell casey aj
bouillier one of the better guards in
football and graham glasgow melvin
gordon at running back holy cow draft
killed it
killed the draft and you add two weapons
with a quarterback that you're excited
about and we're excited about noah
phantom and cortland sutton and phillip
lindsey already and now you're going
whoa jerry judy and kj hamler like you
know get the hell out of here that's
exciting so i think when you just look
at it from that aspect let alone some of
the mainstays that were already there in
denver when you talk about von miller
and bradley chubb's gonna be back and
justin simmons is one of the best better
safeties in football and kareem
jackson's one of the better safeties in
football you look at their team and you
go well damn yeah florio's crazy but i
understand him putting them there you
know there's a lot to like about the
roster and then
added to that right
there's nothing to question about the
coaching staff so i think when you have
those two things you know i'm not mad at
you for putting them where you put them
i i understand your logic there and even
though it's kind of an unproven
commodity to this point
and i'm a believer in pat shurmur as an
offensive coordinator look it's kind of
like wade phillips and norv turner where
you do so well repeatedly as the
coordinator you get hired to be a coach
that doesn't work
you go back to be a coordinator that
does work and eventually they realize
probably coordinator is the best spot
for this guy and that may work to the
advantage of the denver broncos i just
think across the board it just feels
like now is the time the only problem is
they're stuck in a division with the
kansas city chiefs yeah right no matter
how good they are this year no matter
how much better they can be they've got
a ceiling and who knows maybe maybe vic
fangio has devoted the entire seven
months maybe in the pandemic lockdown he
was cracking the code on how to finally
stymie patrick mahomes
i i don't know that anybody's ever gonna
figure out a way to completely shut him
down but if your offense is better and
that may be what the broncos realize
right you know what we can we can try
unsuccessfully to slow down the chiefs
offense or we can try to outscore it and
i think that's what the broncos are
going for i i mean i i think there is
logic to that you know i think vic
fangio looks at it and goes wait my
defense is pretty damn good i got some
good talent here i know how to game plan
you know yeah you always got to worry
about the teams in your division so he's
going to go okay my defense i think i
can slow down my homes and company
but like slowing down my homes and
company is different than slowing down
the rest of the nfl world in the history
of the nfl world because slowing down
the homes and company means what 24
points 28 points so to what you're
saying mike your offense is still going
to have to be very explosive and make
some plays there because i just yeah if
you're in the afc west right now you
can't just think like oh we're going to
win two defensive battles every year
against kansas city that's insane it's
not going to happen sorry so you better
have some fireworks on the offensive
side of the ball to answer it every now
and then to think like ooh my home's
entirety kill no matter what i do might
go off might have the perfect defense
call for 40 snaps in a row and they
still might score six touchdowns so
that's where it's it's cool that they
did take that approach because the
defense was set in place there now
they've improved the offense with these
weapons you know to me the only thing i
worry about with the broncos right now
mike
is a little bit of like
cleveland last year okay
that would be the only thing you know
and not to the like the extent of
cleveland with the obj and oh my gosh
cleveland's going to the super bowl i
mean we all went crazy with that last
year but i do think you know i just hope
denver's not reading their press
clippings i guess is what i'm saying i
hope they're willing to put in the work
and realize they haven't done it yet
yeah there's a lot to be excited about i
just don't want to get them what's they
what do they say too far in front of
their britches is that right am i good
there
too big for their british too big for
their party for the horse right
somewhere in there somewhere in there
the two together okay here's the thing
first of all press clippings don't exist
anymore second of all
if they're reading press clippings
they're not coming from a lot of
different publications this isn't like
the browns last year where everybody was
anointing them as a surefire playoff
team and maybe a super bowl contender
and actually jimmy haslam the owner of
the browns acknowledged on sunday they
did a bad job of managing expectations
last year yes we've only been saying it
for a year that they did a bad job of
managing expectations they failed to
manage expectations and then even though
they had a season that by brown
standards was far from horrible it felt
like a failure i don't sense that same
buzz around the broncos i feel like this
is a team that
that the minority at most a a
significant minority at the very most is
looking at saying hey they can be pretty
good this year because the reality is
they're still stuck in the same division
with the chiefs so i don't think they're
going to stand out like a team that
otherwise would that were pointing at
and saying hey they could be pretty good
this year so i don't think that that's
quite it's quite as big of a problem as
maybe it could be no no yeah i think
you're right and it was good for you to
put that in perspective because
you're right in the fact that cleveland
overtook the national story that's not
happening in denver you know what mike
i'm bored drawing from
i'm going on radio stations out there
and i can hear the excitement of the fan
base the radio host they expect big
things they were mad at me that i put
drew lock you know in the mid-20s in my
quarterback rankings they think he's
already better than that you know so i
guess that's where i was drawing from
but you're right it's not in the level
of what we saw from cleveland last year
i guess my point was just i'm just
worried about so many young guys so much
talent oh things look good pat shurmur's
here all that stuff that you know you
know like i said maybe uh they they lose
their focus a little but i think the
kansas city point you make is very real
that is gonna keep people on their toes
if you're in that division no matter how
confident you are because you're gonna
go damn we're not as good as that guy 15
and we're certainly not as good as them
the super bowl
yeah it's the pistons in the bulls from
all those years ago as michael jordan
company tried to get past detroit the
problem is michael jordan plays for
detroit and uh good luck getting past
good luck getting past the chiefs
anytime soon if you're the denver
broncos all right our friends at
draftkings have the over under for drew
locks passing yardage production this
year at 3
450.
are you taking the over
knowing that we don't we don't have a
full season to compare it to no i know
but it's the injury i'm going over i am
i'm going over you know i just look at
first off him his skill set the weapons
we've already mentioned you know there's
there's a receiver for every little
thing you want to do
shurmur is going to stay patient with
the run game he's got a great play
action passing attack off the run game
which i really like and i think drew
drew locke will fit right in with the
the patch ermer scheme
and do some of the things you know we
saw case keenum do in that year in
minnesota and saw a little bit of daniel
jones do last year to where i go
no i mean i'm expecting 4 000 yards from
drew luck i am i think this is they're
going to run the ball yes but i still
think this offense is going to go
through drew lock's right arm and those
those weapons he has available to him
yeah i agree with you as well to the
extent that people are looking for an
intriguing prop bet i think the over
34.50 that's if that's what draftkings
is making available they may want to
bump that up a little bit before people
start going crazy on the over because
i'd agree with you i'd take the over as
well i think 39.50 would be a more
appropriate over under read for drew
locked in 34.50 all right we talked
about the weapons that he has here's an
exercise for you chris rank the top
three yards from scrimmage leaders for
the broncos this this year you've got
melvin gordon and philip lindsay in the
backfield you've got all the receivers
who are going to be the top three guys
when it comes to produce your producing
yardage i'm gonna go cortland sutton
number one because i think he's a
special like he's one of those guys you
can formulate game plans around or not
formulate anything around him and just
go you go out there and let's see how
they handle you oh you're covered oh it
doesn't matter you're 6'4 and a freak
we'll just throw it up and you'll still
catch it so i'm gonna go cortland sutton
one because i think the two running
backs are gonna share some carries there
that'll like cancel each other out
after that i am i think i'm gonna go
jerry judy too i'm gonna go jerry judy
too
and then
[Music]
i think i'm gonna go phillip lindsay
number three
i think that's where i'm gonna
interesting i know i mean melvin i'm not
sure yeah
i think philip lindsay gordon said over
the weekend so that's the only reason i
guess i i edged that way
melvin gordon said over the weekend he's
struggling to get used to the thin air
in denver now look i'm surprised after
being there this long
that's still an issue it you should be
through that by now but he's still got
another month to get himself ready for
the first game i i i think what they
play the titans uh the monday night is
that what it is denver and the titans on
the first monday night of the season the
late game i think that is um
yeah i i think sutton
then after that it gets very giant
look i i think i think what's going to
happen with gordon and lindsay frankly
and because of the position they play
somebody's going to get injured but it's
going to open the door for the other guy
to to
produce more that that i feel like at
some point you're going to have a
stretch where one of those two guys is
getting the bulk of the touches because
the other guy's banged up because we
know how the running back position goes
in the nfl the defense they were top
five every year from 2013 through 2017
fell to 22nd in 2018 back up to 12th
last year can they get back into the
upper echelon of the nfl chris a very
very good uh enunciation there with
echelon uh yes i do believe they can a
second year in the vic fangio defense
you know more pieces that fit his scheme
and you know what his overall vision is
i think all of those things let alone
you know
like we we mentioned a little while ago
i mean arguably their second best player
maybe their best player on defense
wasn't there last year bradley chubb i
mean he's he's going to be in that
conversation and really okay i i
misspoke there von miller we know is
still their best player he didn't play
his best last year it was not von
miller's best year so i just think when
i look at it like that and it was still
a great year don't get me wrong but when
i look at it like that and go okay i
think von miller is ready to prove some
people wrong bradley chubb coming back
jarrell casey you know simmons bouilla
at corner you know i do i think this
defense will be better than last year
more dominant you know one because i'm
hoping they'll be healthier have a
better idea of what the scheme is and
all the details of it
and the thing about bradley chubb and
this happens every year when somebody
gets injured fairly early and they're
gone they become out of sight out of
mind let's not forget about bradley
chubb he had a great rookie season from
a production standpoint von miller is
motivated to turn it around and come
back and and have a big year and
reestablish himself i don't know if this
defense can be top five but again i
don't think it's gonna need to be top
five because i think this denver team is
moving toward
if you can't beat them out score them
and that's the attitude they're going to
bring to the afc west as they try to get
past the chiefs and they're not going to
concede anything they're not going to
concede to the chiefs they're going to
come after them
what do you see though chris as being
the best case and worst case for the
broncos this year all right like
absolute best case uh
i you know again i don't see them
winning the afc west i think i'm right
there with you but i could see them
being a pain in the butt and competing
with the the chiefs to win the afc west
like late into the year where we're
going man look at the broncos you know
the broncos win two out of the last
three and if the chiefs lose two out of
the last three they win the division or
something like that i i certainly so
like best case i'm gonna say
11 and five
and you know in the wild card round
worst case i don't see this is i would
be shocked if this team fell far i just
don't see it i think there's too much
talent to where i want to go like i mean
absolute worst would be six and ten but
i really believe like seven and nine
might be the floor but i guess i'll say
six and ten since we're saying worst
worst case scenario
i think best case for this team is the
five seat
i i don't think they can win the
division although you never know what
may have you know crazier things have
happened than the broncos
finding a way to leapfrog the chiefs i
mean maybe the chiefs come out and can't
handle having the target on their backs
yeah they've been talking too much about
winning six or seven championships and
they're gonna get uh you know a cold
splash of water in their faces this year
but i think realistically five seed for
the broncos
and worst case yeah i mean i can't look
it just i i've
i'd be shocked
losing season yeah right
they've had three straight losing
seasons that's the first time that's
happened for the broncos since 70 71 and
72.
i think anything less than eight and
eight just isn't gonna happen i think if
john elway has to put a helmet on and go
out there and play himself at any
position to keep it from happening he'll
do it they're gonna be determined to not
go worse than eight and eight this year
so you know i know that's a high floor
but i just i don't see this broadcast
team being you know the way it's been
the last three years it feels different
this year i'm with you i can't seem
worse than seven and nine yeah i'm with
you you know maybe it goes six and ten
if they had some rash of injuries and
some star players missed i don't know
but you know like stay in the status quo
i just i don't see a low floor for this
team either
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports